(grunting)
- Fucking shit!
(laughing)
(upbeat rock music)
- Tap, tap, tap, tap.
- Hey guys we're at Ncuti's House.
(Ncuti laughing)
And we're gonna be
- Welcome to the crib.
- I love your house, Ncuti.
- Thank you.
- It's so nice, look at all the art.
- This is what happens
when you're in Vogue,
you get a house like this.
- [Kedar] Yeah.
(Ncuti laughs)
- We are gonna find out
who is the best gamer,
so lets play and let's find out.
(techno music)
- Obviously I'm Donkey Kong.
- [Connor] Do you remember
the controls, Ncuti?
- No!
Nobody's explained it.
- All right, so this is go,
this is break,
this is drift.
(Kedar imitating car drifting)
All right, what's the fun
stage, we want a fun one.
Here we go.
- Oh my god so this is what I was playing
in season one.
Wait I really, that was some real acting.
(game countdown beeping)
- Bro...
(laughing)
- You pressed pause, bruh.
- What happened?
(laughing)
- [Connor] Ncuti is top
right, I am bottom right,
Asa is top left,
Kedar is bottom left.
- [Kedar] Is the winner.
- [Asa] Come and get me. Watch
out for my banana though.
- All right you dropped it there,
but lucky for you, there was
a big ass cow in the way.
- Mooove, blud.
You get it?
That was clever.
- [Connor] Are you breaking
as you go around corners, Asa?
- [Asa] Yeah.
- You break?
- Tightly, I just tap the break once.
- You tap it once, you tap the break once?
- Yeah, I will tap that break.
- Tap that break.
- Right.
- What's break again?
- [Asa] Ncuti you're going backwards!
- Oh my fucking word, this is a piss take!
(Kedar laughs)
I've ended up somehow on the ceiling.
- Get your hand out my face.
Do you know what I've just realized?
I'm gonna have to sacrifice
comedic commentary
to win.
Why am I not turning?
- [Asa] No, watch out!
- Yeah!
- No!
(yelling)
descending game bleeping)
- Has everyone finished?
(slight laughter)
This is...
- You lot, go start dinner, yeah?
(Kedar laughs) I'll be with you in a sec.
(slight laughter)
(soft music)
- Oi oi, so what've we got 'ere then?
I have brought,
Some jollof, Ghanaian jollof.
and I've brought kelewele.
Now obviously,
Eric is half Nigerian, half Ghanaian
so that's why I brought some jollof.
- Fresh out the oven?
- And some plantains
fresh out the oven!
We only do fresh cooking around here.
No takeaway shit.
- Ncuti didn't tell us
that he was cooking.
- I brought some sushi.
Here we go, I've got some soy sauce.
- But the thing is, I didn't
actually cook it though,
you know that isn't it?
(laughs loudly)
- Anyway, I've brought like a china mas--
Like, not even china masala,
like a sort of Indian kind of ting,
just safety, innit?
- Some garlic naan.
Love a nice garlic naan.
- [Asa] Garlic naan?
- Garlic naan.
You not a fan of garlic naan?
- I usually go for plain
though, to be honest.
- Just plain?
- Really?
- Just bread?
- [Asa] Yeah.
- And I bought a pizza, it didn't come.
- It didn't come (laughs).
- There you go.
- [All Together] Cheers!
- Should we start sharing
out some of your food?
- Yeah, lets eat.
- Oh, yes!
- Smash, cup, bam!
Pizza's here.
- Pizza's here, bam!
Thanks.
Thank you, sir.
- [Connor] What is that?
- [Ncuti] It's plantain.
- What color did you say this was?
- Have I got any?
There seems to be a film
crew (laughs loudly)
My god!
What are you guys doing here?
- Got a question,
from the question box.
(plastic bag rustling)
I'd love you to keep
going through that bag
as I'm about to read.
- (laughing) Go on.
(giggling)
- Who surprised you the most
once you got to know them on set?
- Probably you, Connor.
- Connor.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, Connor.
- That's our laugh because it's you!
- Yeah, it's me.
(laughs loudly)
- He's just very sweet.
He is a very, very sweet, lovely boy.
Okay, so what's the weirdest
thing you've been asked
in an interview, in an audition.
We don't interview (laughs).
- I've done an air kiss in an audition
where in the sides it
said, "And now they kiss"
and I've gone (blows kiss)
- Have you? (laughs)
- What happened?
- I think they were
like, "could you try it,
could you try to make it
a little more, kind of..."
- Urban.
- You know that one? (laughs loudly)
You know that one there!
Make it a little bit more urban.
- What's the most show-biz
thing you've ever done,
or experienced?
- Present in a BAFTA.
It was pretty, it felt pretty show-biz.
Because that was weird,
just it looked like
Madame Tussauds, but everyone was moving.
I was like, rah, this is real.
Like, everyone was moving.
That was pretty exciting.
- If you could cast yourself in any part
from any film ever, what would you be?
- Neo in "The Matrix".
- That's a good one.
- Yeah.
- Jay Gatsby.
- I almost called my cat Gatsby.
- It's a good cat name.
- Yeah!
they've got mustache, no?
- Well, they've got whiskers.
- Would you rather win an Oscar,
or get to travel to space?
- Travel to space.
- What?
- An Oscar would look better on my social.
- Oh my days.
- (laughing loudly) No, travel
to space, travel to space.
- Connor is not a fan.
- (laughing) He's not a fan.
- Head in hands.
- I wouldn't even do
it if it was 100% safe.
- Really?
(Ncuti laughs loudly)
- What do you miss most
when you're not on the set of Sex Ed?
- The people.
- Yeah.
- I see you guys now and then,
but a lot of most of the
crew I don't see until
at like a screening, or
people are in London,
or we go back to Wales.
- I'll be brutally honest,
I didn't hear the question.
(slight laughter)
- Did you do any particular
research for your role;
how did you get into character?
- I chatted to my mom a bit
because my mom's a therapist,
but I didn't really do
anything to get into character.
- I guess I looked to the
relationship I have with my mom,
and how strong that is
and how much of an
influence that has had on me
I guess, as I've grown up.
- What's the best and worst
parts about your jobs as actors?
- Best part of acting I
think is meeting people
who you'd never get to meet
and kind of form friendships
and relationships.
Worst part of acting.
- I think what you said
before about the fact
you know, you get to
meet people and stuff.
I think for me, that what happens after
you have to then just
say bye to those people
that you form this thing with,
that you'll never actually get again.
- So you're saying that the
best and worst part about it
is the same thing?
- I find it.
- You've got the wettest meals,
have you just got soups?
- Thanks for watching.